der günstige schoko pudding mit
sahnehaube gehört in jedes kühlregal
sebastian weiß wie die discounter das
billigste sehr herstellen wie kakao
braucht er dafür nicht heute machen wir
schokoladenpudding wir kennen denn alle
mit sahne und top aber schokolade sowie
wie sie kennt brauchen wir dafür ganz so
gar nicht mit einem pudding wie von oma
hat das industrieprodukt wenig zu tun
denn der wäre zu teuer
[Musik]
zu vermitteln
so und jetzt machen wir schon heute
alles im mixer grundzutat ist meistens
über milch allerdings and rand mit
höchstens 0,5 prozent wie in dem nur die
wasser milch auf deutsch gesagt dann
natürlich wie in allen günstigen speisen
ganz ganz viel zucker 30 gramm für einen
becher sogar noch gute laune bis infekt
bei sahne ist heraus natürlich immer
pflanzenfett ist immer günstiger wie
tierische fette das hier ist keine party
droge sondern mono die blitze riede von
speise fettsäuren der mit der pudding
schön glänzend samtig weich wert und
alles sich miteinander super verbindet
billiger pudding billige zutaten so
lassen sich bei der massenproduktion
millionen sparen
[Musik]
omas pudding wird durch stärke und werne
zusammengehalten billiger ist gelatine
ist ein tierisches produkt wird meistens
aus dem spalt der tiere gewonnen ja
spalt ist das was zwischen haut und fett
liegt 90 prozent davon ist vom schwein
weil es da natürlich auch am günstigsten
ist
kleine risse im pudding für vegetarier
und muslime ist dass discounter produkt
schon mal nicht geeignet und wo bleibt
die schokolade sophie kakaopulver kommt
bestimmt nicht rein
cacau ist teuer verkaufen wertvoller
rohstoff und maximal ein bis zwei
prozent mehr wird nun zum fertigen
schokopudding ihr einkommen nur ein
prozent kakaopulver ist gesetzlich
vorgeschrieben
der geschmack entsteht durch aromen
[Musik]
aber was wäre der schoko pudding oder
das fluffig luftige sahnehäubchen und ob
damit die sahne auf fluffig luftig lange
im becher erhalten bleibt müssen wir
hier auch ein bisschen nachhelfen
ein kleiner stabilisator wir schauen uns
auch nicht stark sondern hier mit gar
tierische gelatine tigers stoffe und
aromen für den geschmack so wird aus und
rannte milch und zucker ein günstiger
schuppen putin
[Musik]
ich würde sagen
sieht aus wie das produkt das wir aus
unserem krieger erkennen mit einem
prozent schokolade mit viel luftiger
sahne die auch lange luftig bleibt
[Musik]
im discounter vergleich zeigt sich bei
lidl ist am wenigsten cacau im pudding
nur ein prozent das gesetzliche
mindestmaß netto und penny verarbeiten
immerhin 40 prozent mehr kakao als
vorgeschrieben
und das zum gleichen preis tierische
lawine beinhalten alle schokopudding es
denn bei diesem billigen preisen müssen
die discounter einfach an guten zutaten
sparen
ihr wollt keine tierische relative in
eurem projekt dann kocht ihn lieber
selbst doch welcher hersteller bietet
den besten geschmack und die einfachste
zubereitet wir machen den test
alle drei puddings werden mit den exakt
gleichen zutaten zubereitet zucker und
milch mehr braucht es nicht
die gelingen garantie testen für uns
drei kochanfänger clara und marie haben
die drei überhaupt schon ein pudding
gekocht tatsächlich nicht jeder tester
kocht einen der puddings vorher lesen
sich alle einmal durch was sie zu tun
haben
tim bereitet die neue variante von gut
und günstig zu clara auf dem pudding der
marke ruf
und marie hat dr edgar gezogen alles
klar
[Musik]
es wird gut geschildert was ich machen
muss ich hoffe dass sich das auch dann
so hinkriegen also ich glaube so
unterschiedlich wird es nicht sein
tatsächlich die anleitungen sind
praktisch gleich erst einen halben liter
milch abmessen davon eine geringe menge
in eine schüssel geben und mit 40 gramm
zucker und den pudding pulver verrühren
schon ist der erste schritt geschafft
[Musik]
den pudding bildschirm fast so schön
sehr macht dr oetker bisher einen
unterschied eigentlich gleich auf
kleinen kochen werden alle drei gleich
zubereitet als erstes die milch
aufkochen danach den topf vom herd
nehmen
dann kommt die pudding mischung in die
heiße milch und nochmal auf den herd
stellen noch mal kurz aufkochen fertig
beim abfüllen zeigen sich erste
unterschiede der pudding von gut und
günstig ist nicht so glatt geworden wie
die anderen die jungköche fällen ihr
urteil sehr gut und günstig kollege hat
klümpchen drin
eigentlich darf sich so viel falsch kann
man nicht machen außer die milch anderen
zu lassen und das ist ja hier nicht der
fall gewesen
und wie gut es der pudding von dr edgar
gelungen also sehr fällt also der drk
pulling ist so fest geworden
trotz billing garantie also darauf
pudding ist ja von der konsistenz her so
wie man ihn sich vorstellen würde von
einem pudding also keine stücke stücken
oder so sondern flüssig oder cremig
innen drin hat ruft den marktführer drk
also wirklich geschlagen
jetzt nach dem test würde ich eher den
ruf pudding kaufen
vor dem test hatte ich auch auf jeden
fall den drk putin gekauft
wahrscheinlich weil ich einfach darauf
hereinfalle dass es eine bekannte marke
ist der ist auch kein großer unterschied
dann sehe ich dass es halt nur die marke
die man dann halt eben entsprechend
braucht also beruf ist auch mein favorit
drk hat nicht versagt aber das für sie
bessere ergebnis haben unsere koch leyen
mit dem ruf pudding erzielt aber was
geschieht wenn ein produkt tatsächlich
einmal überhaupt nicht gelingt wie weit
geht dr gass geling garantie wir machen
den test und rufen bei dr oetker an
wir geben vor dass ein pudding klumpig
wurde ein anderer sei uns angebrannt und
der käsekuchen trotz back hilfe
eingefallen
wir fordern unser geld zurück
[Musik]
wenige tage später erhalten wir die
antwort als entschädigung bekommen wir
puddings und back helfen in den
beiliegenden briefen entschuldigt sich
dr oetker für die misslungenen produkte
unser geld erhalten wir aber nicht
zurück ist das alles was hinter der
geling garantie steckt
wir fragen in der konzernzentrale beim
verbraucherservice nach hier nehmen
zwölf mitarbeiter die anrufe von kunden
entgegen
100000 anfragen kommen im jahr bei ihnen
an
dazu zählen auch die produkt beschwerden
spaß drk seine kunden immer nur mit
warmen worten und puddingpulver ab der
verbraucher hat bei uns ein produkt
gekauft was eine gute qualität haben
soll was schmeckt was gelingen soll
und wenn er da einen berichtigten mangel
hat und das auch bei uns vor bringt dann
gibt's ein kleines trostpflaster in form
von leckeren pudding statt einer echten
garantie gibt es also standardmäßig
trostpflaster haben kunden keine
möglichkeit ihr geld zurückzubekommen
wir haben ja keine geld zurück garantie
das steht nicht auf unseren produkten
drauf sondern eben die geling garantie
und wenn eben die zubereitung anleitung
wirklich exakt eingehalten wird
funktioniert das produkt auch also
bedeutet das konkret ein kunde hat nicht
die möglichkeit sein geld
zurückzubekommen
im normalfall nicht was wäre dann der
ausnahmefall
den gibt es nicht kostproben aus dem
sortiment statt geld zurück aus sicht
der verbraucherschützer hat das mit
einer garantien nichts zu tun
es ist erstmal eine gute werbemasche
denn der verbraucher denkt vielleicht
kann ich nicht so gut kuchen backen aber
mit den produkten muss es auf jeden fall
klappen
die verbraucher haben rechtlich gesehen
wahrscheinlich keinen anspruch auf diese
gelinge garantie aber sie sollten sich
trotzdem beschweren wenn ein hersteller
schon dieses versprechen gibt dann
sollte man immer rückmelden wenn es
nicht geklappt hat doch dr oetker wertet
jede einzelne rückmeldung aus profitiert
der konzern dadurch nicht am ende mehr
als die kunden
das ist völlig ausgeglichen wir geben
den verbrauchern dann wirklich gelingen
sichere und gute produkte aber es gibt
immer die möglichkeit etwas zu
verbessern oder anders zu machen es gibt
ideen in den haushalten und wenn wir uns
natürlich das ganze dann zurück spielen
und uns ihre erfahrungen berichten
warum nicht durch die vielen anrufe
erhält das unternehmen also gratis
informationen über die vorlieben seiner
kunden
damit bringt die geling garantie vor
allem einem etwas drk zelt
[Musik]
hört ihr euren pudding selbst an oder
kräfte liebe zum becher sagt es uns in
den kommentaren
und wenn ihr noch mehr über euer essen
wissen wollt dann abonnier die zdf
besser esser und schaut in die nächsten
zwei clips